[Música]
hicimos un trabajo aquí bueno yo
personalmente con otras docentes de
ciudad de méxico en donde alineamos los
contenidos de la plataforma de can
academic con el modelo académico de
conalep o sea con los módulos que
nosotros trabajamos normalmente pues
cuando iniciamos el mestre nosotros
aplicamos un examen diagnóstico para
saber cómo es que vienen preparados los
chicos ahí nosotros pues ya detectamos
las deficiencias con las que vienen y
aparte que trabajamos la plataforma aquí
en la escuela pues esas actividades se
asignan fuera de la escuela para que
ellos las trabajen en casa y más o menos
ya en un tiempo de un mes dos meses
podamos arrancar todos desde el mismo
punto nuestros para evitar que chicos se
nos vayan a trazando de acuerdo a mi
programa establezco el tema la fecha
tenemos que empatar todo eso y éste
previamente yo doy la introducción en el
aula y vamos a la práctica es la manera
en que se planea
[Música]
aquí en el liceo hemos tenido todo el
apoyo de parte de la dirección
directores para
a organizar el horario de trabajo porque
ya habíamos iniciado en marzo nosotros
hemos empezado en abril con el can
académico entonces ya habíamos
planificado el taller de matemática y
hablé y explique de qué se trataba el
trabajo con él cada academia inmediata
me dijo villa perfecto a esas dos horas
de taller va a ser las horas del can
académico y es así como dos horas a la
semana tenemos acá en el liceo dentro de
las dos horas también este planificó un
vídeo del tema que vamos a trabajar
paralelamente teoría y dos prácticas
y eso es lo que trabajamos en las dos
horas pero algunos tienen diferentes
ritmos de aprendizaje
unos termina más rápido otros todavía
les falta entonces éste le dio me puedo
basar si puedes continuar puedes buscar
qué es lo que podemos hacer en innova
nosotros trabajamos esta plataforma en
realidad en el área de matemática
tenemos tres sesiones grupo y una sesión
de solo no en las en la sesión de solo
que es en el área de matemática
asignamos y trabajamos con la plataforma
de khan academy que es una vez a la
semana en un bloque de 80 minutos no
donde los estudiantes van y puedan
trabajar de ellos el proceso es que
nosotros vamos asignando temas no de
acuerdo a las actividades que nosotros
vamos trabajando en la semana no estoy
asignando un bloque de ejercicios de
vídeos de acuerdo a lo que nosotros
vamos trabajando en las actividades en
la sesión de grupo
en las sesiones nosotros podemos darnos
cuenta que estudiantes presentan
dificultad o que estudiantes se están
estancando en temas no asignados
entonces si yo en mis sesiones grupo
identifico chicos que están presentando
dificultades no en un tema x entonces
ahí es donde yo asigno de repente tareas
diferenciadas en ellos no
bueno el curso del complemento de
matemática es un curso que está dirigido
a estudiantes recién ingresantes de la
universidad privada del norte el
objetivo del curso es que los
estudiantes puedan desarrollar
habilidades competencias que les
permitan resolver no sólo los problemas
matemáticos sino también problemas
contextualizados son diversas áreas no
tenemos alumnos por ejemplo de
psicología de derecho de economía de
ingeniería el curso complemento de
matemática es un curso que se dicta a
alumnos o estudiantes de diferentes
carreras son varias veces eficiencias
las que ellos traen o por ejemplo en la
parte del razonamiento lógico-matemático
a veces en lo que tiene que ver con el
la comprensión de un problema matemático
sobre todo en la parte de la
conceptualización tu denuncia es un
problema y el estudiante a veces lee el
problema y no entiende en los datos del
problema no entiende que le pide el
problema y por esa razón no encuentra el
camino para la solución yo creo que
decirles a ellos que tienen que ingresar
a un medio virtual y aprender y sacar
provecho de ese medio
es como una fantasía a veces es como que
de verdad o sea me van a explicar un
vídeo voy a resolver ejercicios y voy a
poder seguir intentando resolverlos
hasta que me salga o sea decirles esas
cosas para ellos la verdad es a veces
poco creíble por eso es que yo considero
importantísimo y eso lo hago el primer
día de clase que ellos puedan visualizar
la plataforma la plataforma khan academy
se ajusta precisamente a los temas de
los cursos que enseñamos en la
universidad
es importante para el aprendizaje de la
matemática que el alumno siempre esté
permanentemente practicando una vez que
termina la clase presencial con nosotros
es difícil seguir más aún si son alumnos
que trabajan entonces la tecnología de
acá tiene temas de nuestro curso y
empieza el alumno a practicar la ayuda
que tiene cada académica es la
complementación del aprendizaje a
nosotros nos escuchan practican en la
pizarra pero es poco para el aprendizaje
de la matemática cuando ellos van
avanzando con esta plataforma nos ayuda
tremendamente porque regresan a la
siguiente clase y el alumno ya avanzó
entonces tiene que ser semanal
hay que echarle muchas ganas los
primeros que nos debemos de quitar las
barreras somos los maestros para
decirles a los chavos se puede si se
puede lo pueden hacer yo creo que el
primer punto que debemos de tener como
docentes es el interés de seguir
queriendo aprender e ir indagando bueno
primero que revise sus y la hbo en sí
luego de su curso para que pueda ubicar
de manera ordenada todas los contenidos
que tiene can académico porque caja
también tiene infinidad de contenidos
muy valiosos y así pueda él organizar
los contenidos del campo para sus citas
tienen mis inicios yo utilizaba a la
plataforma como un poco para saber con
lo que es la matemática un poco más allá
ya que yo soy estudiante de los años 80
y hoy bueno la matemática ha
revolucionado y bastante
en este aspecto si yo soy bastante auto
formativo no
yo como docente también investigó en la
matemática un poco más profunda así
tener un nivel porque por ahí puede
encontrar un estudiante que me ha puesto
y esto como es no entonces uno como
docente siempre tiene que estar en este
caso esté a la vanguardia del estudiante
qué es lo que quieres lograr con tus
estudiantes también en este caso sabemos
que khan academy no solamente tiene
matemáticas tiene diferentes áreas e
involucrarte involucrarte con la
plataforma tienes que investigar no que
para qué sirve esto cómo puedo asignar a
los estudiantes como forma mis clases y
qué cuestionario qué vídeos relacionar
hemos visto que ahora también khan
academy está formado por grupos y
habilidades también que los sociedades
tienen que reconocer no entonces la
sugerencia es que tú investigues
investigas que qué
herramienta es la ideal para ti
e
[Música]